impressive way to start this ball game
dion johnson out of tennessee
21st pick last year has
five ivy another three ball this one is
pure
get some defensive drills in the
all-around game but nothing mark takes
the place of putting time in spending
time with the coaches
in practice your man just hit a three
right there
cars are trying to post up got
bayheim on his back but they turn it
over two on one ivy on the alley-oop
showtime
in vegas nice job by key you've talked
about it he's made a number of good
plays that call tonight doris i saw that
eye roll
mia ivy mom
oh come on now
off the kickout
[Applause]
that's what he does
an imperious dynamic
i watched ross playing the west coast
conference tournament
a couple of seasons ago and he was
really good and that's really good ivy
ball kind of slipped out of his hands it
looked like doris 100
ivy turns a corner boy that's a big time
finish
[Music]
exhibiting his
best strength offensively
[Applause]
women's basketball program at
notre dame
mama player coach ivy and one count it
yeah that left hand is working
in full effect
and all kinds of trouble containing him
off the dribble not a clean switch
he gets turned
and if he's going downhill the kind of
creativity hang time athleticism could
be a long night folks gonna get an
opportunity with the wizards
young man out of duke didn't get a lot
of playing time
with the blue devils
great hit ahead and one